hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to the glitch
detraction I'm Not Dead
I don't care what anybody said I'm Not
Dead rumors are untrue I didn't die then
no way no how I encroached Tesla coils
press the button near the hallways to
turn on the Tesla coils they will be on
for five seconds after that they will
recharge for 10 seconds
control panel party room press the blue
button to turn on the room lights for a
few seconds press the red button to
start the shock gun be careful if you
use the shotgun for no reason too many
times the animatronic will attack before
the shotgun is operational
controller panel breaker room press the
top blue button to activate Bonbon and
control Funtime Freddy be careful if you
activate Bonbon for no reason too many
times Funtime Freddy will get very angry
part sender to order a part select the
part you want on the Monitor and wait to
return a part place a part on the part
Center and select Return part on the
monitor note if you need to exchange a
broken part return the broken one and
order a new one
robot repair collect the missing parts
to their respective places and fuse them
using the main monitor to repair the
robot wow Freedom complete the puzzles
and get out of the room before someone
gets you
that's a lot of information I'm gonna
die many many many many many many many
many
that's nice
nice oh what wait a minute
everything is okay
no no one is here
I don't know if that's well that's a
problem
take some of this oh maybe I might have
missed time that dude man the time was
just so goddamn perfect for you wasn't
it
oh
all right fine whatever at least I get
an eyeful before I die oh it's dark I
still got it
well maybe I deserve death the room
system will alert you if Funtime
foxy is corrupting but sometimes it will
be a false alarm Okay so I'll get
alerted
so I get alerted when that's happening
so that I don't need to do anything
about it is what you're saying oh I
forgot my flashlight's Burke
Okay so
select a CPU on the main monitor
CPU input what do you mean
foreign
what do I do
[Music]
whoa all right so far so good
unless I'm doing terribly on this which
I would never know
okay connect the CPU to the main monitor
uh CPU input oh I see I see so do I need
to grab it from you
where's your CPU
apologies ma'am I don't know where this
would be
you all right over here oops that's not
what I meant
oh
I didn't mean to do that
I'm gonna say that straight up I didn't
mean to do that I thought I pressed the
light bulb button
oh I was Bruce
that don't sound good
all right CPU
oh boy
enjoy
okey-dokey am I supposed to be checking
on you guys
team you're fine all right
give me a
scope scope of what did I see something
that you didn't Lexi did you see
something I didn't see nothing what did
what did they see what what are you
talking about
I got a left Army
Wham
okay
left arm fuse fuse fuse fuse
I don't know I oh god
oh what in the world are you talking
about
all right let's try that again uh let's
actually get the the CPU in time this
time okay it's not there
there it is wham
left arm
all right
oh boy
you come early
[Music]
party mode seems good
why do they gotta be on the opposite of
wapsody
all right let me just start with the
head I guess
nine three nine three
two
nine
five
six
seven six seven four six seven four
three one
seven six seven four three one no
God damn it I pressed mother oh you son
of a [__]
oh you son of a [__] oh
okay so that sound
I bet that's what it is with the thing
you son of a [__]
you son of a [__] six six
[Music]
two six
two
one
well that's that's uh wait a minute but
oh yeah oh no it must be you then take
this
[Music]
five six six two oh God I'm not gonna
see that am I
you're not gonna show it to me are you
Frick you
I know you suck so hard eight nine two
eight nine two six six three eight nine
two six six three fuse okay done are we
good still I have no idea how I would
ever know how would I ever know you're
fine
you look good
so good
it's so good
so good okay
still good
well must be you then right no no one is
here
probably didn't ruin that
oh boy
[Music]
damn it
uh Frick
oh my God oh my God back up back up back
up no get out of the way
you still good
you better be good how about you you
still good probably yeah you look good
uh you you look good you look great
actually fantastic
that's what I've always thought
oh frick it is really a puzzle here huh
that's not good
stop that you oh frick oh well that's
bad it must have been you
[Music]
or maybe that doesn't mean anything at
all maybe I don't know what that means
maybe I don't know anything that's going
on here okay so it's it's just gotta go
straight here but so it must
come in from
up no it can't
it's the only place it could is like
this
but the only way that could go there is
if this is going up there
which doesn't allow for that so it's got
to come
oh frick
who's grumbling
who's grumbling you're grumbling stop
grumbling
[Music]
there we go got it
okay wow that took forever
you okay over there oh that looked good
you look fine to me I don't know what
I'm supposed to be gleaning you look 100
okay I think
so I think it's better just to work
backwards right that's what seems to
work
huh
I think you're fine I don't really know
I don't like that
oh God
the red lights I bet indicate how many
bad things I have oh no I'm a bad boy
you upset with me
God damn it that doesn't sound good
I don't like that I don't like hey it is
I don't like hiatus
I usually fine I don't know
there we go got it okay
okay that's two that I got two holy crap
I got two
you okay
what's up
what's the deal
you mad
oh I'm I'm Buffalo boned I'm full boned
that's five lights I'm five lights at
Freddy oh I'm faboned
I'm flown
oh I'm well I don't know if the lights
mean anything
the left leg
oh come on please
oh
my God okay
[Music]
what
oh oh
God I didn't realize it until whoa
you're fine
again don't really know what it means
if you're not
fine
you seem fine
you seem less fine
you're you're fine are you fine
[Music]
something didn't seem fine I don't know
so it's upside down I'm stupid so we
gotta rotate it twice so
thank you
red okay and then that means this would
I just did it
okay no
God that's not right
this
[Music]
rotate this Frick you're supposed to be
there oh boy oh boy
oh God
hello long time no sleep Laura
that was almost too late
okay okay where was it oh really
interesting
that's fascinating
[Music]
spicy
yellow blue okay blue blue blue red
sneezing blue red blue
uh blue and then dark blue check presses
okay got that one hell me oh my God oh
my God
I must not have gotten it in time
holy crap oh wow wait
it's loading the CPU oh it's got an arm
in it oh it's it's saved a bit
oh good
oh good I managed to save it just a
little bit just a little bit oh save me
some time thank you for that
oh man that would have been awful
that would have been just horrible
okay let me check I'm probably not
making it in time who's doing it you
yeah you look a little a little
different so it's like a pose change
[Music]
what
it's a very slight pose change but the
hand goes down I think
or at least something like that I don't
know there we go oh I was right there
duh
[Music]
oh oh you
can't see
come on
I might be doing that completely wrong
but if I do die from it then at least it
will let me know what I did wrong oh
defective part god damn it
all right effective part
oh [__]
U
foreign
part
oh
where are you
oh you were closer that's what it is you
get closer
ah interesting
your right leg
we're all good
okay so flip it up and around so let's
go this is Pink
this is oh that was green this is light
blue this is red oh that was supposed to
be red red
purple back out check
check
you're fine uh blue red
blue red got it okay good checking
[Music]
fine
maybe we'll see I'm still not 100 sure
oh boy oh God get it get it get it get
it get it get it
oh yay
still good
oh boy I don't see you
holy crap yeah let's go back to our
stage oh my God
oh my God
[Music]
okay let's do this
all right you're right there oh man that
hurts my brain okay flip it upside down
whatever so this is yellow
light blue
this is red oh
that's it stop cutting
you're fine you moving
you in your spot oh you're in your spot
you're fine
God I just get my brain wrapped around
it and then I'm like where do I go okay
frick
which I get is the point
[Music]
yellow
light blue red light blue
this is
oh frick no that's oh man oh wow I'm an
idiot this is red
light blue
oh frick
[Music]
go back
oh man I did that all wrong okay yellow
green
light blue
[Music]
thank you
in your spot you're good
uh check
scope mode
activated for easier transport please
leave the room going through the right
hall to start the animatronics
transportation
through the right hall way what
okay
I don't know what that means
oh
right from my right you meant I did it
scoop mode what is scoop mode what scoop
mode
what what school mode
what is scoop mode oh
what is scoop mode
hey
[Music]
press to go down dance it's the elevator
wow
[Music]
damn I'm always impressed by the
faithful Recreations never mind
[Music]
hahaha
oh
oh that's not good